اللحظات الأخيرة
لرحلة الطائرة العسكرية الروسية وهي تغوص على
الأرض على ما يبدو خارجة عن
السيطرة بعد اصطدام الطائرة بانفجار
كرة نارية عملاقة لم أسمع سوى انفجارين
يقول شاهد العيان إن الأول كان دويًا
باهتًا ثم انفجارًا ثم لهبًا كبيرًا
وسائل إعلام روسية  يظهر الحطام
متناثرًا في منطقة كبيرة في
موقع التحطم، تقول السلطات إنه لم ينج أحد على
متن الطائرة، بما في ذلك 65
أسير حرب أوكرانيًا مريضًا ليتم تبادلهم في
نفس اليوم الذي ألقت فيه موسكو اللوم على كييف في
الحادث، حيث أطلق الجانب الأوكراني
صاروخ دفاع جوي من جانب هارف
قال وزير الخارجية الروسي إنها
استهدفت الطائرة وكانت
ضربة قاتلة ولم ينفي الأوكرانيون
إسقاط الطائرة، لكن كيف يقول إن
الروس لم يخبروهم أبدًا أنهم
سيسافرون بالطائرة الأوكرانية إلى بلغراد،
محملين موسكو المسؤولية عن الخسائر في
الأرواح والأرواح.  التبادل الفاشل إن هبوط
طائرة نقل في منطقة قتال بطول 30 كيلومترًا
لا يمكن أن يكون آمنًا وعلى أي حال يجب
مناقشته من قبل الجانبين لأنه
بخلاف ذلك يعرض
عملية التبادل بأكملها للخطر،
يقول بيان للاستخبارات العسكرية بناءً على ذلك ربما
نتحدث عن مخطط ومتعمد
تصرفات الاتحاد الروسي لزعزعة
استقرار الوضع في أوكرانيا
وإضعاف الدعم الدولي
لبلدنا تقول أوكرانيا إن روسيا تستخدم في كثير من الأحيان
طائرات الشحن i76 لنقل الصواريخ
المستخدمة لاستهداف المدن الأوكرانية والبنية
التحتية المدنية، وهو الهجوم الأخير الذي أسفر عن مقتل
وإصابة العشرات في هارف في
شمال شرق أوكرانيا.  بدأ الهجوم الصاروخي،
ركعت بالقرب من الغسالة، هذه
المرأة تقول انظر، لقد أصابني شيء ما هنا
زجاج زجاجي ولكني على قيد الحياة، مات بعض الأشخاص
وذهبت شقتي، تعهد
الأوكرانيون بالانتقام
من الهجمات الصاروخية مثل هذه ويقولون
إنهم يعتبرون البضائع الروسية  الطائرات التي
تنقل الصواريخ لتكون أهدافا مشروعة